we have a new candidate for president
that man's name Tim Scott I'm announcing
today
that I'm running
for president
of the United States
of America let's get her ready to rumble
but under Joe Biden our nation is not a
nation in Decline but under Joe Biden we
have become a nation in Retreat Tim
Scott to his credit is launching a
different kind of campaign than his
competitors in the Republican field Tim
Scott is launching a campaign premised
on America is not in Decline every other
candidate Trump DeSantis the bank Nikki
are there other candidate maybe ASA
Hutchinson there's some other candidates
in the race Joe Exotic they're running
campaigns based on how America is in
steep decline we've got to turn that
around Tim Scott says we are not in
Decline